Ja, läuft.
Nice.
Die epische Musik im Hintergrund.
Wenn jetzt der Chat noch gehts, alles gut.
So, posten wir den ganzen Krempel mal auf Twitter, oder?
Komm, nee, wir spielen uns erst mal eins, zwei Games ein.
Ich entweite dich.
Na, hast du Angst, dass man dich beim Sacken sieht, ja?
Ja.
Ist nicht gut.
Ich sage dir später schon genug, da muss man nicht die volle Sackladung kriegen.
Ja, wenn dann der Twitch auch noch anfängt, so.
Was ist das für Play, Lull und so.
Genau, genau.
Genau. Echt so.
Moin, es sind richtig viele Leute da hier.
Der Flipk, GP, Mr. Santa, Halbkorn, Shadowghost, Kiyokun,
Astea0a15, Woodpecker155X, alle schon am Start.
Die Zuschaueranzeige geht mal wieder auf Twitch, nicht?
Weiß nicht, wie viele Leute am Start sind.
Null. Das kann nicht sein.
Egal, ich queue einfach, okay?
Bist du ready?
Alles Geister, ja.
So, und nachher müssen wir Lootbox aufmachen.
Ich habe sechs Winterlootboxes, das geht nicht.
Das muss weg.
Jetzt geht der Chat wieder nicht.
Also irgendwie ist Twitch in letzter Zeit ein bisschen kaputt.
By the way, wenn du mal Bock hast, können wir ja mal wieder,
oder können mal Rainbow Six Siege reinschnuppern.
Ohje, ich bin halt richtig schlecht.
Ich habe das Game in der Beta mal gespielt, also Rainbow Six,
in der Beta gespielt, danach nie wieder.
Ja gut, ich habe es ja auch in der Ewigkeit nicht mehr angehört,
so gesehen.
Ja, das stimmt schon, dafür warst du halt mal richtig gut in dem Game.
Ja, es ist halt, ich sage mal so, ein paar Fracks wirst du wahrscheinlich schon machen.
Ja, ein paar Fracks.
Wir haben es sogar auf der Gamescom gemacht.
Da haben wir so alle gefrackt am Ubisoft Stand.
Aber du weißt, was da spielt, ja?
Da spielen die allergrößten Noobs.
So hier erstmal so, Mama, darf ich hier auch spielen?
Die haben sie nicht reingelassen, aber so die übelsten Casual-Leute.
Wir hatten einen von irgendeinem, das könnte sogar von der GameStar gewesen sein,
ich weiß nicht mehr.
Es war alles so schlecht.
Ich glaube, es war nicht GameStar, es war aber irgendetwas Bekanntes.
Was gibt es da sonst noch?
PC Games?
Nee, PC Games war es nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, es war sogar die GameStar.
Die waren so schlecht alle.
Wir haben damals schon quasi aus Versehen die Noob-Scrats entdeckt mit Schild und Gekämpfe und so.
Das waren noch Zeiten, wo du mit fünf Rekordschilds durchgefrischt hast.
Das geilste Event war, ich glaube, es war die gleiche Gamescom, wo Hardline angesagt war.
Und in Hardline haben sie doch diesen Fake, ich nenne es mal Fake-Competitive-Modus probiert.
So quasi auch ohne Respawn, ich weiß gar nicht mehr.
Chat, mal eine Frage an euch.
Wisst ihr noch, wie dieser Modus in Hardline hieß?
Oh Moment, ich brauche...
Oh nee, ich muss Mercy spielen.
Huge Mercy Plays, Leute, huge.
Es gab auch diesen Modus in Hardline, ohne Respawn und 6 gegen 6 und so mit Lagehäusern und so.
Quasi dieses Rainbow Six-Light.
Das war geil, da war es so gaunt.
Da war es so krass gaunt.
Moment, äh...
Wir gehen jetzt teilweise rechts und teilweise links und ich bin auch nicht da, ne?
Noch nicht mal ansatzweise da.
Ich fliege aber gleich zu dir.
Huge Mercy Plays.
Huge.
Oh, oh, oh, ich kriege übelst auf die Fresse.
Was war...
Wo laufen wir bitte schön lang?
Was ist das für ein Weg?
Ich damage booste dich mal.
Uh, schön gesaved.
Okay, okay, ich habe Schiss, ich habe Schiss.
Äh, links ist ein McCree.
Also auch raus, rumgeflankt.
Ich kriege es voll ab, ne?
Und es geht keiner rein.
Winston, Winston, geh rein, Alter.
Alter, Winston, geh hin.
Die wollen nicht, oder?
Ich glaube, die wollen nicht.
Äh...
Ich fliege mal zu Winston rüber.
Okay, go, go jetzt.
Ich habe, ich habe Valk an.
Ihr könnt rein.
Gehuckt.
Kannst du mich halten?
Nice.
Der Winston.
Alter, Alter.
Ich kann nichts machen.
Das wäre schön.
Wir haben keinen zweiten DPS.
Warum ist da keiner reingegangen?
Was war denn das wieder für eine Kacke?
Der Winston, er hat die ganze Zeit in der Ecke gestanden.
Ich muss mal kurz in Voice chat rein.
Erstmal Toxik rausspeisen.
Toxik, richtig Toxik.
Cakes can never be hard.
Big Shack.
Okay.
Ich höre McCree über uns.
McCree ist über uns.
Ich bin bei unseren Leuten drüben.
área
Ich höre mein Creep über uns, mein Creep ist über uns.
Ich bin bei unseren Leuten drüben.
Unser Xen ist flanked, flanked Xen.
Leute geht doch, na jetzt müssen wir auch nicht rein.
Kicks not hot.
Oben, oben, oben, oben über uns mein Creep.
Kannst du mich heilen?
Ich bin cross down.
Ich hab gleich wieder Valk.
Gleich Valk am Start.
Ich schieße vorne rein.
Go in.
Scheiße.
Was sagen wir, haben die irgendwie, trauen die sich alle nett oder was?
Hey, hey, hey.
Ich hab mir halt einen doppel Valk, doppel Trance und so und da geht keiner rein.
Ich krieg Anfälle wieder.
Ich hab die Trance halt bislang auch noch keine Blutzpumpe ausgeworfen, wenn ich das richtig
sehe.
Da, ich glaube einmal auf den Boden.
Klasse.
Hinter dir, Hawk, Hawk.
Ach fuck, nicht hinter dir, sorry.
Ich bin.
Am Arsch.
Ähm, ich hab mich verguckt, das warst du gar nicht, das war unsere Tracer.
Aber das ist echt lächerlich gerade, was hier abgeht.
Geht gut los.
Yeah.
Warum haben die Leute eigentlich immer so einen Schiss zu fighten?
Ich mein du fightest, verreckst und probierst es wieder, aber es bringt doch nichts, wenn
du eine Minute davor AD-AD-Spam machst und weder vorwärts noch rückwärts gehst.
Das hat doch einfach keinen Sinn.
Ich gucke hier jetzt gerade mal.
Huge Mercy Plays.
Also die Leute, was wir im Team haben, die haben null Playtime, das ist ein Spätsünder.
Ja, ich sehs, 1 Stunde, 3 Stunden, 2, nein doch, der Widow Typ, der Widow Soldier Typ,
der feed me more.
Wir müssen was anderes spielen, lass uns mal irgendwas ordentliches, ja wobei, jetzt
ist ja nur noch so Port-au-Prich.
Kann da irgendeiner Mercy von denen spielen, hat der ja ein bisschen Mercy Playtime, würd
ich den Zen rausholen, irgendwas, anders, irgendwas wo ich ein bisschen mehr mitmachen
kann als mit Mercy.
Ja, du hast auch mal ne Idee wer, um das Spiel ein bisschen mehr competitive zu machen im
Range.
Die Placement-Matches abschalten, 3 Wochen vor Seasonende, damit die Leute nicht so auf
den letzten Drücker da mit ihren Decaten, Accounts und ungespielten.
Ich find das ist ne gute Idee, ich find das ist ne gute Idee, hab schon noch keine Gedanken
drüber gemacht.
Icecold hat kein Mercy spielen, wir sind ja schon zu zweit.
Du merkst halt immer richtig, gegen Seasonende nimmt die Qualität von den Matches so dermaßen
ab.
Wann ist denn die?
Weißt du, wann die vorbei ist, die Season?
Äh, jetzt zunächst dann, so in 2, 2 und einhalb Wochen, glaub ich.
9 Tage.
Ach, deswegen sind die Matches so räudig, weil die Season so was vorbei ist, verstehe.
Es ist halt, es ist richtig schlimm für mich, wenn die ganzen Spätsünder kommen, die sonst
gar nicht spielen, ne, und die decayen halt auch nicht richtig.
Ja, weil intern ist MMA, ich weiß ja auch immer noch nicht so genau, wofür das eigentlich
da ist.
So.
Jetzt.
Scatter.
Wenn gar nichts mehr hilft, mach einfach Hanso.
Rechts, ich hör rechts was, ich hab rechts irgendwas gehört.
Ja, ist Tresor unten, die kommt aber nicht.
Links, links, links, ich geh mal runter, ich schieß genau dahin, wo ich bin.
Ich bin wieder da, drin.
Ich muss runter, ich muss runter, unser Torb kriegt dick auf die Fresse, Tresor hinter
mir, hier unten.
Äh, ich komm zu dir.
Torb, du Spaß, lass mir da den, den, den Pack.
Ich hab dich.
Äh, wir müssen die rechts wegfaschen.
Wir müssen da jetzt mal was killen.
Die haben rechts hier, äh, Dings Sombas den ganzen Tag.
Boah, Glück gehabt.
Ich hab Damage Boost auf dich drauf.
Und die Gegner sucken ja auch, so ist das ja nett.
Ich hab übrigens noch, ich hab noch keine Wahl, ganz vergessen.
Ich versuch den mal zu retten.
Ja, super, perfekt.
Bestes Match, bestes Match.
Eiskäuter, ich glaub die...
Ja, weil die Gegner nicht wirklich gesackt waren, die haben einfach nur gewartet auf die
Sombra ulti.
Ja, das war auch gut mit Mercy ulti und so rein.
Äh, Eiskäuter, das ist gar nicht mal so, dass die Teammates rollen oder so, das war
einfach, das war einfach schlecht.
Einfach mega schlecht.
So, du kannst doch keine, keine 1-2 Minuten vorm Spot spielen.
Ich mein, das Schwierige ist ja oftmals bei diesen Maps, du musst, dass du überhaupt
richtig raufkommst, richtig rankommst an den Spot, so.
Und wenn du dann an dem, wenn du dann auch quasi vor dem Spot stehst und nicht drauf
gehst, ist das eigentlich das bescheuertste, was du machen kannst.
Und die sind halt 1-2 Minuten vor dem Spot rumgerannt, haben wie verrückt AD, AD, AD
gespammt.
Wir hatten sogar 1-2 Picks, aber es ist keiner drauf.
Es ist einfach, niemand ist in.
Außerdem haben sie mich Mercy spielen lassen, das ist, das ist schonmal wieder.
Na ja, zum Einspielen.
Geht ja.
Ja, das Schlimme ist, man kann sich, auf Mercy ereignet es sich ja noch nicht mal richtig
zum Einspielen.
Hauptsache zum Rechtsklick halten, zum Linksklick halten.
Ja, ich bin jetzt gerade auch schon überlegen, ob ich jetzt überhaupt noch bis Season Ende
irgendein Match mache auf dem Main-Account oder ob ich den jetzt einfach so stehen lasse.
Ich queue gleich weiter.
Jojo.
Was?
Bei dir ist ein Torb in-Game gejolt und hat gesagt, ich trolle das Spiel.
Ja gut, es gibt Leute, die schwätzen halt immer viel Scheiße, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Es gibt auch Welte, das, was ich am schlimmsten finde, sind die, die nach dem ersten verlorenen
Teamfight GG schreiben und anfangen, das Team zu flamen.
Das Schlimme ist, dass es bei dir auf Master so ist.
Ja.
Ich hab das Gefühl, es ist auf Master noch schlimmer als woanders.
Ich weiß auch nicht warum.
Max kommt noch ein Video zur Switch, wie der momentane Stand von ihr ist.
Ganz ehrlich, ich hatte meine Switch jetzt zuletzt an für Mario Odyssey und da hat sich
nicht wirklich was getan, es gibt immer noch keinen Browser, es gibt immer noch nichts
im Endeffekt.
Außer, dass im Marketplace ziemlich unsortiert Games am Start sind, die halt, die sind halt
da.
Die sind halt da, haben keine Bewertungsfunktionen, du weißt nicht, ob sie taugen.
Hallo?
Oh man, ich bin falsch, falscher Chat.
Ich glaube, wir kriegen schon wieder das richtige Team zum verlieren.
Was ist denn das?
Ich kriege Anfälle, wenn ich die ganze Zeit Mercy spielen muss und wenn ich dann Mercy
spiele und dann zuschauen muss, wie es verkackt wird, dann kriege ich durch.
Also ich meine, an sich ist es ja nicht schlecht, aber die Fahrer brauchen wir nicht unbedingt
oder einmal die Widow, es ist eigentlich übelst kacke.
Genji ist okay, da kann ich mit dem Genji vorne rein.
Komm, wir spielen Support, easy.
Auf, komm, wir spielen, lass irgendeine Support-Tour spielen, als würdest du direkt.
Ich hätte bloß gerne den Tank.
Roadhog.
Du kannst Winston spielen, aber nee, jetzt haben wir drei Support.
Du kannst Winston spielen.
Nee, nee, lass mich, will ich nicht.
Willst du nicht?
Nee, mit diesem ganzen Insta-Gibs-Scheiß, spiele ich keinen Tank mehr.
Was, was, was ist das jetzt jetzt, blick, ich nehm mal durch, äh, okay, gut.
Jetzt hat er Hanzo geswitcht, okay, das ist, Hanzo ist natürlich zum, zum Diven mit Winston
zusammen viel besser als Genji.
Muss, muss man, muss man verstehen.
Ich bin hauptsächlich auf der links, auf der Ferra, guck mal, wie ich hier rauskomme.
Ich hoffe, ich, Sauer, please, ich hoffe, die hält was.
Farah, mach was.
Auf, auf Farah, geh da mit.
Oh, direkt mal alles gepörpert.
Nice, jetzt geht, jetzt macht keiner was, jetzt geht keiner rein.
Hanzo wird halt gerückt.
Ich hab einen Ludenpistel auf mir, der trifft aber nix.
Oh fuck, ich bin gerückt.
AD, AD, Spam, ja, Reiss kommt.
Okay, Pusherino.
Okay, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du.
Okay, du, du, du, du.
Gut.
Okay, wir killen was, du pusht, du pusht, perfekt.
Nice.
ich habe ulti
bleib bei der fahrung
ich mach den rest
ich fahre als hinten auf dem payload
jetzt
ok ich geh hoch mit ihr
nice so nice so nice so
war der reaper oben, reaper, piss dich alter
auf fahrer
was hast du für uns
ok jetzt gib ihn
ich bin mal der fahrer
hast du keine gehalten? fast schon
yolo fahrer
fahr schon runter
alle schön gepiloptet da drinnen
unten links
oh ich bin über dem, wenn ich pesch hab fliege ich da voll rein
fahr ein bisschen hier, falls du was hast
huge mercy plays leute hier
wo ist unsere fahrer
pass auf ich glaube ich hör was von hinten
bolt kommt demnächst
ist die fahrer wieder am start
hat sie schneiden lassen
ich könnte die retzen aber ich finde nichts
die ist halt auf der plattform gestorben
rein hat gute idee
statt schild oben halten zu chargern mit 10 hp
so ich hab ulti wir gehen gleich rein
rawtalk nicht sterben jetzt wenns geht
ich hab schiss ging die weder
wow knapp
rechts die widow in der mitte main
den kann ich denn jetzt boosten?
schätze
fuck fuck fuck
C9? seh ich das richtig?
seh ich das richtig?
war das ein echter C9?
an deinem mercy gameplay musst du noch arbeiten max ja ich bin ja auch bekannt für meine
krassen huge mercy plays
ja aber alles kreut er dann erzähl doch mal was muss ich denn machen
hallo vollpfosten
kleine obito ist auch wieder am start
bin fast wieder gm
die sind jetzt ja auch fast vorbei
gibts da ein huge reward am ende
ich könnte es euch nach der runde posten auf youtube und twitter
zum beispiel beim resten hinter gegenständen verstecken ja das ist schwierig wenn da nix ist
oder wenn du von der falschen seite kommst
hast mitbekommen dass ich zu sie wieder gewandt wurde
ich hab auch mitbekommen dass er wohl irgendwie ein entschuldigungsvideo hochgeladen hat
hab ich aber noch nicht angeguckt
aber ich muss ehrlich sagen ich finde diese ganze hexenjagd bei xqc echt übertrieben
jemand der 12 stunden oder was weiß ich wie viel am tag
20 stunden gefühlt am tag
overwatch spielt
dass man da mal nicht
100 prozent gibt in jede match
ab und an mal ansonsten ist er immer übelst dabei
also man muss das echt nicht übertreiben
du bist auf deinem smurf höher als auf deinem mate ja es kommt vor
ich auch
fast fast zumindest
weil das ja gar kein richtiger smurf ist
pass auf die fahrer wird jetzt gesniped
haben die ne widow siehst du was
ne haben sie nicht
ins gefahre haut ab
ich glaube schon
fahrer spamm doch da ein bisschen drauf
wort hat muss gehilfshut werden
ja wenn er mal ins zeitkomm ich gebe doch meine position nicht auf
fahrer mach was alter
jetzt
kannst du was fressen
ach nee die warme ich weiß nichts dort
huge massive place
die war aber dreiziger geht vielleicht drauf
samus und sollte das mal ein bisschen aufpassen
ich hab noch kein ulti
ich muss uns ein roter kallen dass ich ulti krieg ich klick halt
der lebt noch ein bisschen
ich brauche einen jetzt sonst bin ich nicht im range
das ist schon das letzte
fuck zu spät
ich setze gleich wieder schlafen
wir können das halt mal die antihilne ist so nice
ich liebe sie
unsere fahrer mit am start irgendwo
ich bin purple
huge massive place
wow nicht verrecken
oh jetzt haben sie ihn wieder am start
ich rette den
ich muss weg
ich hab schiss
ich hab gleich wieder ulti
da können wir eventuell noch mal regroupen
sofern mich die fahrer gleich stoppt
ja das müssen wir noch mal kontesten können
leute lasst mich zu euch fliegen lasst mich zu euch fliegen
kannst du fliegen? ja bin da
okay go go
roter musst jetzt go go
ich guck gleich chat
roter ist übelst overextendert des todes
oh shit das hat sie gut gemacht das hat sie echt gut gemacht
voll in meinen flugfahrer rein
fail
aufwärme mit mercy ja leute ich muss mercy spielen mir bleibt nichts anderem übrig
spielt gerade aktuell keiner mercy
das ist schlimm
nicht dass ich mercy spielen will
ich will ja gar nicht
ja charge ein bisschen ult das ist gut
das ist bestimmt das pharah one track
ich hoffe dass der jetzt hier gute ulti setzt sonst verlieren wir den spot auch gleich direkt
ich hab zwar mal ne zweifel aber
ich geh mal mit dem winston rüber
huge heals
oh wie knapp
servus moin schaff
was schafelp
das ist glaube ich hardcore mercy one track
wieso switcht der denn die pharah nicht man? das ist pharah one track
die ich mein die haben ich glaub das ist so wie der das im chat geschrieben hat hat sich sehr nach pharah one track gelesen
spielt zen
ich spiele jetzt kein zw ohne mercy kannst du nicht gewinnen das funktioniert nicht
lass mich hochfliegen please schnell
du machst das schon
one track ich halte mich
die leute müssen switchen die dex weder muss weg und die pharah muss auch runter
es ist wahnsinn ey
vor allem das rumgestackere schon wieder seit dem zweiten punkt
nein ohne mercy ist für den arsch zurzeit
ich komm gleich und retze
meine huge mercy plays haben es ja wieder richtig schwierig
scheiße
ich komm mal mit speed wieder vor
ok ne wir habens
oder nicht
i dont know
weiß nicht
du darfst mercy nur nicht retzen lassen sag das mal während der mercy mit der ultra rumfliegt
schnipes haben wir uns halt
und ein solcher das ist halt mal so absolut anti pharah was geht
es keine wieder mehr
ja ich bin hinter unserer pharah
jetzt aber nicht übertreiben
ich guck gleich chat wenn die runde vorbei ist
die haben ja sowas von alles gegen ne pharah am start zurzeit
haben sie geswitcht
ich hab gleich wieder ulti
ich bin gestunt ich krieg getrackt
ich komm aber gleich mit ulti wieder raus
noch 9 prozent das krieg ich schon gebacken
lass mich spawnen alter ach overtime
overtime beste
lass mich retzen lass
oh ich brauch ulti
fuck warum hab ich keinen zweiten retz gekriegt
ach weil das auf timer ist oh gott meine mercy plays
ok jetzt aber
das war kacke
jetzt kommt die traurige realität in overtime durchgepusht noch mal ne minute kriegen
ja over time regeln ist auch was das sein
oh du lext gerade du hast gerade übrigens geleckt
komisch ist jetzt besser
ja ja ja das ist gut
kleine obito ich geb dir insofern reicht dass man dass man eher zentrals
andere hätte spielen können aber nicht ohne mercy mercy ist das opeste was es
zurzeit gibt in overwatch
wusste einfach mal überlegen wenn du nen fight hast ich mein
das ist ja bestimmt bestimmt klar wenn du quasi wenn du gm bist aber wenn du
nen fight hast
du killst auf beiden seiten was
und du kannst retzen ist das wie du hast zusätzliche teammates im
im team
und vor allem wenn du das so ne mercy in der ult auch kaum noch killen kannst
wenn man das ordentlich macht nicht so wie ich einfach reinfliegen
das haben wir ja keine haben wir irgendwas mit schild
ne nicht wirklich
das wissen wir uns darauf verlassen dass die wieder besser ist als die von
gegner
muclot
muclot macht das schon
die werden jetzt gesniped die fahrer hier
oder du wirst ich hab das gerade aufwärmen die fahrrad ist kontra
ich wollte oder ich werde gesniped
ich werde gesniped
haben wir nix mit schild
kleiner opi du das siehst du ich bin tot
gegner kann ohne probleme retzen gegner hat zwei leute mehr im team
genau deswegen brauchst du
brauchst du mercy
müssen wir raus kommt fliegt zu mir
also die wollen das echt noch mal testen
weiß nicht
wenn ich den rotor gleich ulti geben kann könnte das noch was werden
da war mein
was für ein Arsch
ich kann auch sehen
die müssten aber zurückkommen und zwar komplett wir müssen wir müssen vor
allem da zusammen drauf
also wenn der genji jetzt stirbt dann ist
verlieren wir den zweiten checkpoint auch gleich
sniper oben an der tür
äh unsere die war fliegt da drauf kann schon hinterher
perfekt
pro mersey war aber eher
welche hier kommen muss in die besten also zur zeit fährst du eigentlich mit
sein mercy am besten
was macht der genji da am payload
meinte der stolt ist jetzt oder was bis alle da sind
es hat schon wieder so mega verschenkt hätten wir auch wenigstens mal eine cc
ulti
das wäre auch mal toll
und die war kein weg
nein ein hit
die widder ist scharf auf mich
ich kann da nicht rein
ich hab dich
leute geht rein
was zur zeit
mersey senfer so standardmäßig mit abstand am besten zur zeit
wenn du noch zwei leute hast die das ordentlich können
also hier war eine pro mersey plays halt mal jetzt mal außen vor
aber das ist schon wieder so eine sache weißt du eigentlich solltest du jede
einzelne sekunde zum push bekommen jetzt
was die an over time haben
das seh ich auch so
das ganze rumgestag ist halt immer scheiße
aber wenn du in over time keine clear uns hast, dann irgendwas womit du die leute zerrumpen kannst
das finde ich auch, ich finde es okay dass es over time gibt ich meine
letztendlich es hält die matches tatsächlich ein bisschen spannender und es ist auch schöner
guck mal genau wie er es schreibt im chat grad
auch zum zugucken
aber ich mein du kannst es verlieren gegen zwei gute over time pushes obwohl du im
endeffekt schneller warst mit der zeit
oder mehr zeit
schaum ich muss nächste und ich muss so viel mercy und reinheit und geduld
spielen zurzeit
ich guck mal kurz was der typ so spielt
rase mal
falls du noch nicht gekockt hast
ja was meinst du was ist auf dem ersten platz mercy äh äh äh fahrer fahrer
fahrer ist auf dem ersten platz was meinst du was auf dem zweiten platz ist
mercy? ne nichts
er ist fahrer only 76 stunden
hehehehe
ich versuche mal zu retten
boah tock dir kann ich nicht helfen, ich bin da, ich push übrigens gerade ne?
jetzt unser winston alleine drin
macht wenigstens mal einer desire weg
nop gibt es nicht
mercy up
cock open
fack der ist low ey
jetzt die laufen halt weg so weißt du
easy rats
die wird aus rechts oben irgendwo, ich bleib mal unter der tankstelle
sterbe ich puste den schweiler in der zwischenzeit
snipe den mal
ja unser hawks stirbt
the fuck was machen die denn
ich hab gleich ulti
WTF
boah Gott sei dank ist das die öffnung
ok ich verpiss mich mal sofern ich weg komm
und jetzt recoupen wir nochmal ordentlich und dann geh ich mit ulti mit rein
ich mein wir haben übelsten spawnadvantage hier
ich kann denen nicht helfen, ich hab es nicht am start
boah es ist unkoordinierter shit ey
es ist halt unnötig schwierig mit dem helfesten was wir haben
die haben wallhack
ich werd gleich gesniped, ich hab es im urin
ooooh fahrer alter was ist das
ich hab kein ulti
ey es ist lächerlich ey so lächerlich
huge res- ja oh madzip leute
wir könnten einfach mal recoupen und ordentlich engageen so
ich hab schiss vor der widow
ich kann mich halt auch nirgendswo verstecken so richtig
oben rechts sind wir kree
adi adi strafe in der luft perfekt
oah ich bin gehockt fuu
aber es ist schön dass wir auch gestaggart haben
jetzt kommt der kick erst auf der time push des todes
ja die haben wieder den sai, jetzt ist die frage wann sie den graviton schon hat
die müsste bald wieder da sein, die hat sie vorhin am ersten punkt benutzt
wobei die das verletzte runde vergessen
du musst mich resen falls ich down gehe, heb den res auf
hast du trance? ja
rechts ich hör rechts irgendwas rechts leider
nice gehen wir mit
kann ich jetzt rumdrücken? ja
oben, oben ein solter schreit sie unsere fahrer
easy easy easy win easy win easy clap
direkt nice für u
alter, was ne runde
ich bin schon wieder fertig mit nerven
das sah geil aus
wenn der 30 prozent hero damage hatte
das spricht es aber nicht unbedingt für die anderen gerade weil der hat die
zweite hälfte der ersten runde nix mehr gemacht
ja gut er wurde ja auch gebabysittert das ganze game, er wurde gebabysittert aber die
zweite hälfte der ersten runde war nichts
da wo die wieder solter gespielt haben, da ging plus von azaria in diesem
engen raum dann weißt du
der war ja instant immer weg
spiel mal genji nein
ich kann kein genji spielen
ich hab jetzt nicht geguckt, chat wieviel haben wir gekriegt? vielleicht seh ich den stream noch
ich geh mal kurz aufs klo und so
ja dann kann ich chat gucken und ich post jetzt mal auf twitter und so
was ist das eigentlich für ne epische mit dubstep mix musik die wir hier haben
das ist, lasst mal gucken was läuft hier gerade, best of two steps from hell volume 2
die machen
epic music das weiß ich
äh war das das erste game? ich glaub das war das erste game
auf twitter sposten
Leute jemand da der mal ein letztes video gesehen hat das über rainbow six
ne wir spielen jetzt weiter duo queue, wir spielen jetzt weiter duo queue, wir machen kein treistack
soll das ganze jetzt auf youtube posten
ja fandet ihr das echt so schlimm? ich finde die leute also jetzt mal auf das letzte video
ja enden kann ich nicht, mach ich gleich danach
auf das letzte video bezogen, ich finde die leute haben es echt übertrieben
es mag ja sein dass es sich vielleicht nicht jetzt so gut ausgedrückt hat mein dual partner
wie das vielleicht einige gerne hätten aber ganz ehrlich wie er da teilweise geflamed wurde
und diese sinnlose diskussion zwischen konsole und pc und so mir geht das mittlerweile echt so hardcore auf den sack
kann man nicht die leute einfach spielen lassen was sie wollen, man muss doch noch keinen zwangs bekehren irgendwie
ich sehe es auch so das pc an sich die beste platform ist vor allem allround mäßig ja beste spiele für alles
eigentlich aber ganz ehrlich deswegen ist doch keiner ein schlechterer mensch nur weil er konsole spielt
da muss man sich einfach mit abfinden
ich kann es auch oftmals nicht nachvollziehen so richtig die begründung warum manche sagen sie wollen das halt
unbedingt
aber wenn sie wollen ist doch ok
pc master race by the way ja ich sehe es ja persönlich persönlich sehe ich das auch so
persönlich wie ich habe es ja gerade gesagt für mich ist persönlich pc die beste platform
aber ich kann auch jeden verstehen da beispielsweise eine konsole im wohnzimmer stehen hat mein pc im wohnzimmer mit mausklassatur
ist halt eben nicht so dass das nicht so gut ist
ist halt eben nicht so dass das wahre und sagt hey ich will jetzt einfach mal in runde mich an die playstation setzen und irgendwie
an chartet spielen oder so da ist er dadurch nicht schlechter oder so oder weniger gamer oder sowas in der richtung
beides ja wo du klaut das sehe ich auch so man kann einfach beide spielen man spielt einfach das wo einem das jeweilige game am besten vorkommt
beziehungsweise aber meist bock drauf hat ich meine ich habe ich habe das letzte anscheinend auch auf der playstation gespielt bleibt ja auch gar nichts anderes übrig
ne
candy crush master race übrigens habt ihr das mitgekriegt firefox hat ein mr robot addon installiert zur cross promotion ohne zustimmung der user
falls ihr es gelesen habt finde ich auch schon ein hartes stück kriegst du schon vom browser hersteller ohne cdons untergeschoben die du nicht haben willst
auf der anderen seite wenn man sich das anguckt unter windows 10 ist ja permanent so weil hier gerade einer geschrieben hat candy crush
guckst du auf einmal in dein startmenü auf einmal steht da schon candy crush drinne ja ich weiß eiskreuter ist schon wieder aus dem firefox raus aber allein schon das zu machen ist beknackt
so ich poste jetzt mal auf youtube ich poste jetzt mal auf youtube dass ich live bin kommen noch ein paar leute war das eigentlich das erste game stimmt es mit 1 0 überhaupt
oder haben wir davor schon eins gespielt seht ihr mal wie weit man hier schon ist
vor allem von mozilla ja ich verstehe es ehrlich gesagt auch nicht ich meine man muss mal überlegen sie haben jetzt ja mit der neuen firefox version mal seit langem eine version rausgebracht die wirklich durch die bankweg eigentlich positiv angenommen wurde es gibt kritikpunkt so mit addons die nicht funktionieren und so aber es hat sich schon wirklich viel getan das heißt die haben jetzt wirklich richtig was für den ruf getan mit der letzten firefox version und jetzt kommen sie an leute wir schieben euch jetzt mal ein bisschen weiter und dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder im nächsten video
addons unter also quasi ruft schon wieder marsch
google chrome beste wenn du genug ram hast na ich schwöre auf firefox also ich habe ich habe mittlerweile äh lasst mich mal wieder auf google chrome best wenn du genug ram hast
ich schwöre auf firefox also ich habe ich habe mittlerweile äh lasst mich mal überlegen drei browser die ich öfters benutze und vier browser wenn man wenn man noch edge mitzählt den ich auch manchmal angucke einfach um zu zu schauen was da ist also ich benutze ich benutze chrome eigentlich habe ich habe ich fünf ich benutze chrome ich benutze chromium hauptsächlich ähm firefox ist mein main browser also ich benutze eigentlich benutze ich hauptsächlich firefox so sagen wir mal 80 prozent dann chromium
chrome äh vivaldi das sind so die haupt browser die ich habe lootbox soll ich lootbox aufmachen soll ich lootbox aufmachen loot soll ich looten deswegen ist chromium gut ähm es hatte ich kann mich gar nicht mehr dran erinnern warum ich warum ich jetzt warum ich jetzt gesagt habe ich benutze chromium unter windows also ich mein chromium ist ja im endeffekt quasi chrome ohne den ganzen
google shit ähm ich weiß gar nicht mehr was der was der anstoß dessen war dass ich genau ich war doch ich weiß es wieder ähm in chrome haben sie jetzt eingebaut dass du nur noch addons installieren kannst die gescheint sind und aus dem app store kommen aus dem offiziellen google app store für chrome ähm wenn du ein wenn du jetzt einen addon installieren willst entweder ein eigenes oder jemand was der beispielsweise auf github anbietet und du weißt halt ja ich verstehe die
risiken und ja ich will dieses addon installieren zum beispiel war das bei mir ein addon für den bookmark sync mit nextcloud was es äh in der aktuellen version nicht im chrome store gab oder gar nicht im chrome store gab es zumindest im chrome store nicht und deswegen habe ich mir gesagt ich lasse mir noch von google nicht erzählen was für addons ich installieren will und welche nicht
bb ich schätze ich muss lootboxen aufmachen ich muss ich muss mal kurz sechs lootboxen öffnen so was haben wir denn hier drinnen unnütze unnütze player icons beide sind ganz nice das nehmen wir ähm unnütze rotor voice lines eine mercy
neue mercy voice line weil ich bin eine neue mercy main betty meinst du jetzt mit mit chrome und chromium ja du musst chromium installieren es gibt eine Seite mit chromium windows builds nimmst du ein sogar mit auto updater
so was haben wir noch epic skin mcree den hat der hat mir noch das meine hohe mcree playtime wie man jetzt gleich sehen wird von null stunden auf diese account bringt mir jetzt extrem was
äh lass dir noch ein bisschen zeit ich hab grad keine hände ich mach mal ein paar unn
progamer hacks live progamer live hacks das ist auch nice das spray next haben wir hier
mei beste ich hasse diesen charakter also äh also rein vom gameplay her ja ich mei ist das schlimmste mei ist das schlimmste gameplay mir geht das so offen zack dieses einfrier und und vor allem so troll meis mit ice walls und so aber trotzdem muss ich sagen ähm wo ist sie denn hier also wenn ich mich entscheiden müsste zwischen einem overwatch grill die es hier so zur auswahl gibt
dann wäre das eindeutig mei aber aber meilenweit vorne meilenweit vorne besser geht es so eigentlich gar nicht
betty sick super sick widow alter nein widow wird stattnehmen na wofür das ist widow es ist ich weiß nicht wasche zu französisch was haben wir hier sonst noch das braucht keiner
hansu voice line so ok moment ich markier das mal als scene jawoll richtig erkennt man was abgeht die war ich sehe die meinung gehen da auseinander
least favorite overwatch waifu wäre hier eindeutig moira gefällt mir vom design her gar nicht so ist irgendwas dabei gibt es immer einen guten skin jetzt irgendwas was von helden die ich brauche währung währung ist auch gut da kann man was für kaufen
anna voll die oma wobei ohne scheißleute anna wenn wir gerade dabei sind erster platz eindeutig mei und zweiter platz anna aber nicht klassik anna sondern ähm captain amari dies aus als das da kannst du fast schwach werden
ja das haste hände aufgewärmt ok dann cue ich mal also wenn du mich schlaufen hörst sag was ne ne aber ich hab das jetzt ja so gemacht dass ich dich am mixer regeln konnte das ist kein ding wenn du mich schlaust du kannst mich runterdrehen ich cue ok ne passt mir hat nix gehört ok cue ist an
die war aber laut chat ganz schön viele fans hier
meis beste
wie lässt man sich die eigens von den sprechern um links anzeigen es gibt jetzt es gibt im discord in game overlays muss man einschalten und dann dass es funktioniert musst du in obs gehen und in obs noch einschalten dass du overlays capturen möchtest
max was hockst du mit der saria wenn es sich anbietet ich habe season 2 war das ja mal meist gespielt erhält macht doch übels bock als eines meiner lieblings hellen
alles kreuter ich bin für mersey nerf kein bock auf zwangsberg ja sehe ich ähnlich also es müssen eine balance finden zwischen kaputt nerfen und auf extrem baffen
aber ich finde sowohl mersey zu spielen macht keinen spaß gegen mersey zu spielen macht keinen spaß mit mersey zu spielen macht eigentlich auch keinen spaß also eigentlich macht nix an mersey spaß wobei ich da jetzt vielleicht auch schlecht schlechte die mersey main schlecht repräsentiere hier
weil es gibt ganz viele mersey main grills die finden das super dass mersey so gut ist und würden mich wahrscheinlich instant flame wenn ich sag mersey soll nicht mehr so gut sein also musst du aufpassen
vor der horde mersey main grills habe ich respekt da will ich nichts falsches sagen jetzt
ich finde ich fand es eigentlich ganz gut als es noch ein bisschen strukturierter abgelaufen ist als lucian am start hat es einen reinhard am start hat das war so mehr kompakt und mehr teamplay
so wir machen jetzt hier huge huge stand plays machen wir jetzt ich gucke mal ob wir nen mersey main dabei haben ich will nicht wieder mersey spielen ja wolke wolke 18 stunden mersey easy easy
nein warum anna
nein ich spiele jetzt ich spiele kein ich spiele jetzt keine mersey ich kann nicht jedes mal mersey spielen weil wir keinen haben der bock auf mersey hat
anfälle wenn ich die ganze zeit mersey spielen will oh moment was ist das jetzt jetzt muss ich tanken muss man tanken
das hat ja richtig gelohnt die meisten mersey mains haben die schnauze von mersey voll
ernsthaft eiskonter ist das so ich sehe ganz viele mersey mains die mersey mit voller inbrunst spielen das ist so geil
so was ist denn der fuck
tumblr girls oh man so darf ich mal wieder lucian ein bisschen speed machen irgendwas was mir bock macht und nicht mersey
wie auch 42 stunden mersey main haben wir nyst oder oder oder nyst oder was auch immer beste jetzt gehts ab
lucio ist oft meta ja das stimmt aber ich mag lucio und auf king of the hill ist er noch am meta x
ah wir spielen die map mit dem loch kann ich was booten easy easy clap you choose your lucio plays
und orisa zieht sie zieht sie wieder raus haben wir überhaupt nur orisa die haben wir gar nicht
orisa ist auch sehr beliebt hier oh der ist schön aggressiv der winston ich seh schon winston oh hier wird gespammt wir haben wir haben nichts wirklich zum counter spam
oh winston ok ich geh mit ich geh mit ich geh mit easy clap easy clap winston ist down ja das macht keine schild down das ist ein problem
ich kann von der seite reinspam aber das bringt nichts jetzt müssen sie sie müssen zum spot kommen easy cap ok ich versuchte zu knockdown
oh wie knapp also bubble bubble bubble fuck das hat mir den arsch getreten auf welchen setting spielst du alles low alles low
ich sterbe leute ja sieht so aus hier läuft alter alter kommen da so nicht durchgescheit
oh jetzt haben wir nur orisa ich hab spiel und orisa ist fast tot warum wird die nicht geheilt
so was von zerrissen gerade aber hardcore keine max settings nope das ist ja das spam des taunus
von rechts ich liebe overwatch matchmaking beste ich hab gar nicht verstanden warum jetzt
im winston haben wir gar keine pushbar mehr das ist halt weg
sag mal ernsthaft jetzt
reaper kannst du die gegner erstmal töten vor du auf den spot gehst
so die massie könnte man noch holen wenn wir schnell sind hier steht da nämlich drin
moin parkour aber ich meine wie soll er mich er wusste nicht vielleicht hat die massie
ich habe schiss
die runde sieht auf dem papier knapper aus als sie war